I've never seen like a physical fight on
your show before haven't I meant no no
it's not really what we do I mean when
my mom saw that a clip of that she cried
it was like what who are you guys like
what is going on Courtney and I
obviously are fine now but we shut down
production for a week after that I think
everyone was really like shook for a
minute and just was like this isn't like
our type of show
like what's happening we want everyone
to be comfortable and safe Kim
Kardashian on Monday night Tonight Show
with Jimmy Fallon talking about that
physical fight with Courtney fight aired
during Thursday's Keeping Up with the
Kardashians premiere don't ever come at
me like Anton I saw God punch you in
your face so do it I don't really ever
resort to violence like that but she
scratched me so hard
which you guys didn't see I had like I
was bleeding and so you didn't really
get to see that detail when but when I
looked down at my arm and I saw like she
had really scratched me and I felt it
all on my back I just you know went over
and slapped her back so it's not like my
proudest moment but we were going
through it and she's made the decision
to take time off now you mentioned that
you might be ready to say goodbye to
Keeping Up with the Kardashians where
are you at on that um I'm just decided
to spend more time as a mom and you know
put more of my energy there and still
but I'm not saying goodbye right but I
think you'll have to see more of it on
the new season season 18
well Court is taking a step back Kim
says the fam is currently filming their
finale from quarantine so we filmed
everything season I think we're on 80
hour on 18 we filmed the entire season
except for the last episode and we were
in filming and so now that we've shut
down production so we are it'll beat all
of us in quarantine film separately by
ourselves
iPod setup and our iPhone
and the whole last episode will be what
we do in quarantine
tune in because you never know what's
gonna happen
[Music]